thank you very much welcome everybody to
our very own Sona here bear with me for
this second last question of the day
which is about a kind of important topic
it's about the kind of holy grail of app
developers because it's about revenues
and if it's about revenues it's about
money that will make your business grow
so we do the good old hands up game one
more time just to keep you a bit moving
after the break
hands up if you optimize and measure
lifetime value already that's not just
like 20% maybe out of those who keep
your hands up out of those who measure
in optimized lifetime value already how
many of you would do you do it would say
you do it really well and you wouldn't
change a thing if you could well okay I
think we haven't had that in London or
Paris so that's zero percent of the
audience which in turn means to the
presentation is highly relevant so
that's good
lifetime value in the app's world it's
quite a heavy topic especially in the
late afternoon hours we're going to try
to get it to you with this structure
first of all a little bit like in
driving school we're going to go into
the theoretical foundations of lifetime
value modelling and of predictive
analysis and secondly we're going to go
into a bit more practical perspective
applying your theoretical knowledge and
going into best practices that you can
actually use in your own businesses now
let's start directly with the first part
predictive analysis is the underlying
theory that helps you answer any kind of
question you ask yourself about the
future of your business it helps you
answer any kind of or to prove any kind
of hypothesis right or wrong so
predictive analysis is really a theory
lifetime value is part of this theory
but by far not the only one now it
enables you to forecast users behavior
and as you can see on the slide here
this woman seems to have a retail shop
so she's asking herself what products
should I put in my shop like where
should I put the bugs in my shop
how many products would it put should I
put in my shop how frequent will users
or buyers come to my shop and purchase
goods what's the cost of acquiring
customers to my shop and what's the
lifetime value of my product in my of my
users in my shop now for predictive
analysis there are very simple models
that you can apply to answer those
business critical questions and they're
very complex ones simple models could
really be let's say you have a social
app and you're asking a specialist to
give you an analysis of how much revenue
is you could actually make using ad
monetization that's fairly simple and it
helps you understand that question right
or to give the answer to that question
there are also extremely complex models
some of which are really higher maths so
I'm not going to go in depth into those
but be aware that some some structures
like Pareto net phenomenal value and so
on could be important here if you want
to read up on that please feel free to
do so to run predictive analysis who
would have thought so we need data right
and if we want data we need tools so if
you want to answer those if you want to
answer those business questions you have
to be able to put the right data in
right there are three things to remember
here first of all choose the right
metrics come comes kind of obvious
typical metrics would be engagement data
retention data like Nikko and Maxim
talked about before number of active
users you might be expecting frequency
of visits recency of the last purchase
or the last visit and so on and so forth
make sure that you put the variables
that answer the question
secondly the importance of those
variables that you're feeding into the
data models actually depends on a
several on several questions first of
all type of the app if you're a social
app you care about your engagement
whereas if you're a real estate app you
assume that engagement is kind of
cyclical so users will only look for
apartments or houses in a very very few
months of a year or of a decade lastly
depending on the analytical model that
you're actually using importance vary as
well so if you're using a very complex
mathematical model you will need a lot
more data then
if you're using a simple one also the
treatment of data and the ability of
your tool to process it is highly
important so it has to be able to import
data quickly it has to be able to
cluster it according to the question of
the hypothesis you're feeding in and it
has to be able to treat the data quickly
and give the output to you as soon as
you need
the rats data predictive analysis
however doesn't only depend on the data
you have from your analytical tools it
also depends on some contextual factors
one example being do you have a
contractual or a non contractual
relationship to your user a contractual
relationship could be your electricity
bill right or it could be a subscription
in a news app that's a contractual
relationship it gives you already the
lifetime of how long will you get your
fees where you're the money you charge
from the user whereas a non-contractual
the user can just bounce or turn
whenever he or she wants to stop playing
a game stop buying your retail app and
so on so this factor will obviously
influence the predictive analysis as
soon as you're talking about for
instance revenues also predictive
analysis will be influenced by the stage
in which you're in so if you're a
startup and you're very new to the
market you have to persuade a lot of
people that your startup is actually a
good idea
investors stakeholders your users and so
on so you might make more aggressive
assumptions that will reflect in your
predictive analysis model if you're a
mature business you've been around for a
couple of years you know your market you
know your users you will take more
conservative assumptions that also
influences now like I said in the
beginning predictive analysis that's
just a theory because it underlies
lifetime value it's the fear IAM which
is this built why are we talking about
lifetime value why are we giving 45
minutes of our time to lifetime value
and why is it the last session of the
day well because it's really important
so that's why you need to give me your
last bit of attention that you're having
lifetime value makes you understand that
you value that users have for you it
makes you understand what revenue you
will generate in the future it makes you
understand which channels are the right
channels to invest in where should you
put your resource
and what's actually going to be the
outcome what's going to be the dividend
for yourself or for your investors it
can answer you a whole lot of questions
when asking those sorry when asking
those questions can give you a whole lot
of answers a popular example is many
newspaper apps ask me should we invest
in mobile web or should we invest in
apps well essentially you should think
about lifetime value it will help you
it's one of the metrics but it's a good
one to look at if you calculate lifetime
value there are some pitfalls and I want
to point them out before we actually go
into the maths itself first of all make
sure your growth strategy is not just
focused on maximizing lifetime value
like I said it's one metric but it
should be rather an effect than a cost
right
so lifetime value if it increases it
should be the result of actions that you
take on your product when your marketing
strategy and your communication strategy
and so on and so forth
lifetime value should also not be your
competitive advantage so if you have
let's assume you have a lifetime value
of $5,100 and your competitor why why
ever you know that has $50 don't get
lazy on that because it's a temporary
snapshot so if you get lazy on the
higher lifetime value you get and you
don't continue to develop for your users
you this might have bad repercussions a
second point is a too optimistic
lifetime value would lead you to an
excess in investment and we all know
what it means that means you go into the
red numbers remember lifetime value is
based on assumptions so assumptions can
be wrong and the lifetime value
shouldn't be the only criteria and you
should look into different scenarios and
how to calculate it conservative versus
aggressive let's make an example of cost
of acquiring customers in theory the
cost of acquiring customers could be as
equal to lifetime value if it's higher
you're in the red numbers which is a bad
sign only very few investors actually
allow that if it's your growth strategy
a rule of thumb that was told to us is
30 to 40 percent of your lifetime value
should be the maximum that you spend on
customer acquisition
cause now we get to the calculation
later and there's some other things too
to look out for but that's the basic
assumption that's the rule of thumb
right maths so the formula you see here
is the basis of every other lifetime
value formula you're going to find
around right lifetime value depends on
engagement retention monetization I
think it was Maxine who had that on his
slides as well so he took my message
away but it's true they depends on those
three variables lifetime value for a
certain period equals lifetime times
average revenues per user right it
sounds fairly simple now let's look at
the into the different variables first
the lifetime value period so the
lifetime value you're going to get out
of your equations will heavily depend on
the time frame for which you calculated
a user that has a certain lifetime value
for 180 days LTV calculation we have a
very different value for 365 day life
time period calculation what factors
influence your life time period decision
sorry I'm gonna say LTV because I'm
really truly easy to say lifetime value
every time so what factors influence
this first of all the business nature is
your app is your business nature is long
or is it short circle is it
no Olympic Games app which is relevant
for a couple of months or is it in a
software-as-a-service business which
users might be using for years and years
secondly business model advertising
non-contractual business model
subscriptions contractual business model
you'll choose a different life for S or
period and stage of company again will
influence that so startups tend to make
aggressive assumptions so they go for a
longer life life cycle come mature
businesses would go for a shorter one la
mattina on this example has an average
lifetime of their subscriptions of 15
months so that's the lifetime variable
not the period however they decide to
calculate the period for one and for two
years why do they do that because they
want to see how the numbers change
between those two models
right they funnel it together they look
at the aggregate and to take decisions
based on the two isolated to each other
that's for them to understand how it
actually defers that's a nice example
you lifetime calculation now this curve
the retention the survival curve so for
lifetime retention is critical right
because it essentially tells you the
opportunities that you have to convert a
user into a paying user so lifetimes
also highly correlated to engagement
because the more engaged the user is the
more likely he is to really to be
retained the more life time you will
have again there are various very
different ways of calculating life time
some very simple ones and some very
complex ones we heard that before I know
first with a simple model for instance
you would define a moment of churn when
it's churn actually happening for you
let's say you say if a user is two weeks
inactive he's turned that's my
definition of it let's say you look at
your curves and you find out well on
average after six months that's when
users are getting inactive hence that's
my that's my churn and that's my active
that's my average lifetime now there are
also very complex ones which are based
on those survival curves we're going to
get to that later I promise
lastly our monetization metric where
prices come in average revenue per user
now that's typically not that difficult
to determine because it's usually total
monthly revenues divided by man fact if
user is giving you the average revenues
per month make sure that you're doing
that you're taking the right units so
you should have the same units then when
you do a lifetime calculation right now
that's the basic that's the basic
calculation of it now you might ask sir
I have to drink in between because
otherwise I can't bear it um you have
might ask yourself what's cost what
about cost many developers in fact don't
only look at revenues they do look at
costs as well because in real life you
want to know how your net lifetime value
actually looks like so what you would do
is typical top-down method you take the
revenue you earned you deduct all
variable costs and you get into variable
contribute
right so be aware that variable
contribution can vary for different user
segments and that's something also to
look at obviously the more user segments
you define and for the more user
segments you make this analysis the more
tricky it will be in the end to
calculating your lifetime value but it's
worth it also you might ask yourself
well if I am a very long cycle app how
how should I do it with future revenues
that occur far out in the in the future
that's when the discount rate comes in
so like some of you might have learned
in investment calculations you discount
future cash flows into net present value
so that's very important because if you
think about the example if you have 10
euros today those 10 euros won't buy you
the same amount of goods in five years
right inflation so that's something to
take into consideration here because
your investments today will be impacted
by those revenues tomorrow in the best
case scenario will be refinanced that's
something to take into account as well
right so that's it for the theory like I
said in the introduction we will take
the theory first and we will then apply
it into practice now as you see I'm a
passionate motor biker you can see that
here I'm a very passionate motor biker
and together with some of my biker pals
we came up with the idea to develop an
app specifically for motor bikers right
we want to showcase the nicest routes
across Europe the nicest hotels the best
places to drink your non-alcoholic beers
with your bike repels so we came up with
this app idea and we're bootstrapping
this app hence we want to know what's
going to happen with our investment and
how can we refine and set and where
should we invest it in order to
determine which monetization model we
choose we talked to some context we have
across the industry and we wanted to
figure out how they do it with their LT
v8 calculations first of all we found
that it's essentially for pure business
models and many hybrid business models
prevailing in the industry you have
premium apps you have subscriptions you
have
purchases of premium if ads and you have
hybrid models in reality hybrid models
are the most common ones in the industry
let's start with premium the good news
is premium is the easiest to calculate
lifetime value because your LTV
essentially equals the price now the
user acquisition costs also tend to be
very accurately calculated because you
can just paste it on the LTV you're
having or best-case scenario and the net
LTV you're saying now that being said
that is a POV it means usually you will
have hybrid models especially with
premium right we talked to some contacts
at Cameron gong and they were one of the
one of the most popular photography apps
in play so they're having they're having
a premium business model and they told
us that the price is the key for them
and the price has to be right you have
to be able to offer the user the exact
price point he or she is willing to buy
there are doing loads of testing around
these two pounds 99 using price
elasticity testing methods using indices
like the Big Mac index or certain
certain purchasing power indexes in
order to set the right price also for
camel Ringo when it comes to maximizing
lifetime value they're looking into two
main things store ratings and reviews
and store listing we heard a lot about
those topics already today but this
actually confirms it if the moment of
truth truth comes and the user is
supposed to buy in your app before he's
ever seen it or seen anything that may
be a promotional video or screenshots
you have to have good ratings even more
than in on any other model and you have
to have reviews that give direct
feedback that's a bit blurry the best
camera app out there period I've tried
them all
go ahead buy it you'll like it so the
neat though is kind of reviews because
that's the word of mouth that you need
so what are they doing to optimize it
first of all they are super proactive of
customer service goes without saying
they're responding to bad to bad reviews
they're also responding to good reviews
but they're actually they're actually
action name it so that means whenever
they get feedback it's real feedback so
that
worked on it and whenever they get
praise they asked the guy to - to keep
up with his engagement also they're
trying to maximize the ratings so what
they are doing is the typical user
prompt but they don't just prompt the
user whenever they look at loyal users
that they're prompt first they look at
prompting them only when they have good
Network coverage so that they can
actually fill it out they have a nice
mechanism in the in the message that the
user if it doesn't want to be bothered
can just click don't bother me again and
they will try everything not to annoy
the user because nothing is worse than
being prompted the entire time and in
the end you're like okay screw that I'm
gonna give you a one-star right so
that's very that's very important also
their store listing they would never use
human transit we never use spot
translators or Google Translate it would
always use humans because in the end
that has to be natural right store
listing experiments is ingredient
furgus talk to it beforehand talked
about it beforehand
according to come ringo actually the
first time they optimized this entire
funnel or this part of the funnel it led
to 25% increase in downloads well that's
very interesting now we learned about
premium the next thing we wanted to the
next business model we wanted to look at
was of the subscription business we were
because we wanted to take away this pay
without having seen it right and wanted
to increase maybe installs so we looked
at subscriptions now a good a good
friend of mine explained me the
following in subscriptions the ARPU is
fairly straightforward because it's
fixed if you're having your monthly
quarterly your annual subscription and
the rate is fixed so you know that
beforehand the LTV in subscriptions is
really driven by lifetime which is equal
to the average subscription rate that
again depends on the renewal rates that
you're having at the end of the term and
that again depends on churn right
everybody I hope everybody follow me
so churn rates and renewal rates are
crucial that's why life time here in
this example is 1 / turn ratio so this
changed right and it's very concrete you
have to have your rate at your turn
ratio which is the opposite of your
renewal rates now
our poo is fixed lifetime is 1/10 ratio
what about the lifetime value period
now usually lifetime value period should
be your average subscription length
right because you can't you can take
this assumption a priori because you
know what's the average length because
you have this kind of contractual
relationship now in practice many of the
subscription-based developers or
businesses would also calculate based on
180 days or 365 days just like we've
seen before in the example with la
mattina right there are certain caveats
to calculating lifetime value for
subscription-based apps first exclude
free trials right those are not revenues
to exclude them second exclude any form
of promotion or introductory pricing
that you might be doing or at least take
the revenue that you're actually going
to get for them from it secondly segment
by cohorts it's worth it to compare the
different the different lifetimes that
you're actually having so the quarterly
subscription versity annual at least
right thirdly discount future cash flows
because you're having a contractual
business your lifetime might be much
longer hence you need to discount them
net present value fourth cross-platform
attribution now let's take the example
of a newspaper app your business is
across many platforms right so you have
to be able to attribute for lifetime
value across those platforms to compare
it so that means you should be measuring
in the best-case scenario with the same
formula on mobile web on apps on desktop
what's the lifetime value of the
monetization form that you're actually
using right take the formula do you the
percentage in terms of usage and you get
an average to have that's like as a
basis so measurement in subscription app
LT V equals subscription fee times churn
which is subscription fee time times 1 /
turn right there is an interesting
paradox for subscription apps and I'm
not sure how many of you met it and I'm
not gonna do a show of hands again it's
the negative churn paradox so let's
assume my motorbike app only has 2
paying subscribers one of them is Maxime
my colleague here who is a biker as well
and the other is my girlfriend now for
whatever reason Maxime decides after one
year that he's not gonna prolong his
subscription because it's taking tired
of motorbiking so the only customer I
have left this my girlfriend
now 50% of my revenue in theory is gone
and 50% of my users in theory are gone
right however I managed to upsell the
super duper extraordinary VIP package to
my girlfriend for $10 more than the
actual subscription cost of Maxim was
right at 50% use a churn but I have no
but I have 110 percent of revenue so
that's the negative churn paradox you
upsell to the to the users that are most
most engaged at renew their
subscriptions because you can offer them
additional content that's worth it for
them to pay for it and that's what most
successful software as the services or
utilities apps are actually trying to do
upselling to the users that are core
read up on that it's I think it's fairly
it's a very interesting framework we're
not gonna go deeper here but read up on
this DramaFever I talked to a guy at
DramaFever Korean Korean TV series
streaming app right and they analyzed
they in very different cohorts when it
comes to measuring their lifetime value
there you can looking at user life
because for them it's really obviously
the longer that it there is a certain
moment like after 1-2 months of having
subscribed in the app this user will
stick around forever so they built this
loyalty fairly quickly so they will look
at this point of time when they define
their cohorts right they will also look
after for instance churn by payment
methods Visa Debit Visa credit Bank bank
debit this seems to have an impact on
their on their measurement think about
it if it might have for yours and the
annual day they analyze monthly and
annual passes separately because they
see a whole different lifetime value
coming around there some other
interesting points for dramafever churn
rates obey
the last three months so the average of
the last three months they don't take a
very short term metric like one month
just because of data reliability and
significance and they don't take very
long term rates because they're changing
the product continuously so this will
change as well
secondly they calculate net lifetime
value because they want to know about
cost they apply a discount rate going to
net present value because of the long
cycle that not they're trying not to
spend more than 30 to 40% off their LTV
on customer acquisition costs so this
kind of confirms everything that I was
saying before but it's interesting to
see that being put in practice tactics
that maximize lifetime value now I think
we've heard a lot about tactics to
maximize engagement and retention
already they are essentially the same
tactics that you would apply for LTV
because it's depending on those
variables now for DramaFever
interestingly free trials had little to
no impact on the opposite it actually
sometimes had a negative impact because
the user would download an app following
a specific series now the season would
run out of that series before the user
actually ever had to pay for the app
it's at backfired
very often DramaFever also tries to make
want to make their promotions really
impactful so they're offering very few
promotions but they're making sure that
if they offer promotions they're very
good promotions from very appealing to
the user they offer multiple tiers I
think many subscription-based apps do
that giving different different levels
of access and features to the different
users and having different prices which
they test for any user segment that they
might observe as I mentioned before
they're segmenting quite a lot and two
very important points they're minimizing
passive churn and they're trying to
discourage active churn now passive
churn is turn that users encounter
because of some technical difficulty
let's say your credit card is expired so
you can't renew let's say you don't have
sufficient funds in your bank account so
you won't be renewing but that's passive
churn they're trying to have really
proactive customer service realizing as
soon as there is complication and
counteracting it they're also trying to
discourage active churn which is users
just choosing not to renew their
subscriptions how do I do that
they put special
let's put special special deals in front
of the user whose subscription will run
out in the next two weeks and try it to
get him back into the service all right
next up freemium my pals and I were
discussing and we say all of the games
are kind of doing it maybe we should
look into him
in-app purchases and making some of our
content free and having the user pay for
others
now freemium apps LTV depends a lot of
end user engagement right and we see
again the survival curve here when you
talk about lifetime for freemium apps
you're taking a slightly different
approach them with subscriptions in the
lifetime calculation for freemium apps
you're picking reference dates on this
survival curve you're picking one day
for instance seven days and 28 days
you're then looking how does my
historical data for various user cohorts
what data points do I get on those dates
on those reference dates you will get
out an equation which looks like the one
up there where T is the is the day and
ABC are the coefficients now you will
see you will have lots of various
equations so as the next step you're
trying to get out the so a cumulative
deviation of those equations in order to
get to an average and that average would
be your lifetime now I mean that sounds
a little complex but in the end it makes
sense right it's the accurate average
off of your lifetime here now your our
pool that will really be depending on
the units you sold during a certain time
the price of the units you sold so the
calculation is total average revenue in
a period divided by the active users you
have in those people in this period
again look at the time the same time
units please lastly the period usually
SP is a standard you're looking at 180
days or you looking at 365 days so it's
fairly standard because in the end
you're not having any kind of we're
having very flexible churn dates most
presumably in your non-contractual
business model right so the formula as
we have it is the one that we actually
saw in a very beginning
LTV period
was lifetime times are boom okay OkCupid
is one of the biggest dating apps in
Google Play they're actually using two
business models so it's kind of a hybrid
app but we're going to focus on in app
purchases for them for the moment
OkCupid uses an in-house customized
formula so we're not really giving it on
that slide because it includes both of
those business models however there are
certain variables are certain let's say
factors that impact how they set the
variables in a crucial way first of all
they're looking at signals that show
engagement so if user is an active
messaging thread if he's having
conversations with people in their app
that's a signal of engagement so they
would be looking at those to define
engagement retention and churn rates sir
secondly they're also looking at various
various cohorts right again
OkCupid they look for instance below 35
and above 30 35 of age because it shows
that there is major differences between
those years ago horse they're also
looking into genders and they're also
looking at geographies lastly they see
that churn levels typically are very
high but beyond the first usage
retention gets a lot higher so for them
a major major main job is to actually
get users over this first week because
then that's where they get the
engagement that retains them now when it
comes to maximizing LTV OkCupid told us
that for them optimizing conversions for
in-app purchases mainly depends on a
couple of factors first of all they're
trying to optimize creative messaging
calls to action in their messages on
those prompts like you see here one of
them they're trying to customize that
and do a whole lot of testing for
different cohorts for different
geographies genders ages and so on in
order to get the best possible
conversion rate they're also trying to
optimize when they put the prompt based
on the context in which the user is in
right now so if you're in a conversation
or if you're in the kind of who visited
my profile view that's where you get the
prompt because
that's a premium functionality that they
want to sell that so that's how they put
you up to the miracle who was the person
who actually viewed your profile and
again also like like dramafever
beforehand they're very selective with
the promotions so they will only offer
promotions again if they're on high
impact they typically give either
limited time 48 hour maximum give this
kind of urgency to the user or they do
it they do it with a percentage off in
terms of 20% as a minimum usually quite
impactful promotions with this kind of
this kind of testing OkCupid claim that
they've increased 20% in purchases for
the for the eyepiece alright I think I'm
gonna speed up a little bit ads ads
everybody's doing it so we figured we
look into that now The Guardian gave us
some interesting insights here typically
they choose one year as a period for
lifetime alkylation because they say
it's a good way to find out if an if an
investment has actually has an ROI on
which projects they should choose to
focus on lifetime is different for ads
monetization because generally you're
interested in user impressions because
every impression on every screen gives
you an opportunity to monetize that user
s you know so retention is important but
this session like visits sessions per
visit screens per visit and so on that
is really that is really the key of
lifetime calculations The Guardian has a
custom a custom formula also in-house
for this where they essentially look at
those factors and they're trying to get
kind of a normal distribution across all
of those factors in order to determine
their lifetime they won't share that
formula but that's that's how they do it
our pool again that's different here
because with ads as you know the price
varies quite a lot it's based on the
sales channel direct sales indirect
sales the ads formats is it a native ad
is interstitial it depends on the
geographies it depends on the buyers
depends on the users you're having that
the audiences it depends on the context
of where the ads appear and so on and so
forth so loads of different factors
be aware bring it down to one price I
mean that goes without saying
have cost per day cost per mile cost per
whatever bring it down to most commonly
CPM and then get it in fitted into your
fitted into your your equation lifetime
value period may be 360 days 180 days
equals lifetime times average CPM times
average number of ads per month right
again that's the simple that's a basic
formula the ardian adapts this one
segment by cohorts so the Guardian
usually takes four different cohorts for
different users or segments based on
loyalty of those users and the number of
impressions they they they cause also
the cohort they segment those cohorts
into the geographies and they're using
the same lifetime value calculation for
mobile web and perhaps to compare right
last model of the day then we're done
that's all so that's by the way the last
models also where the bike gets much
more fancy
so hybrid models are arguably the most
complex models in lifetime value
calculation because you combine right
you combine different different formulas
now many of the apps are most of the
apps do that because that's how you
maximize it right you try to have a
certain variety of monetization options
that you give to your user because you
want to actually let the user choose
what fits for him what works for him so
here you see for instance a matrix that
Buga Sharapova's popular gaming
developer now you can see on the x-axis
progression of the player in the game
and on the y-axis the spending level now
if a new player comes in and he plays
for a very long time he ends up in that
quadrant that quadrant
muga will serve him interstitial video
interstitial apps because that's where
they get the best prices Nats monitors
because he never spent a dime on their
net purchases now on the other hand if
there is a new player coming downloading
and installing and downloading
downloading and installing the app and
he spends a lot of money in very early
stages he will be immediately offered
VIP packages because that's where
games will try to upsell and include the
user further and further right
that's an interesting model and I think
it shows very well like which user you
would want to offer which kind of
monetization now I'm a big fan of
ultimate guitar tabs' we had a hangout
with them for them they combined two
business model one premium and one is
life is in app purchases premium
lifetime value equals price in-app
purchases they are tearing it down as
well it's interesting actually they told
us that they're having tears of $10
$9.99 $7.99 and $2.99 depending on how
long the user has been has been having
the app pay for downloaded but only
using the basic version so as long as
you have it actually the cheaper it gets
it's interesting to remember if any of
you play the guitar
they claim that 40% of the users are
actually upgrading within within the app
and 65% of their revenues come from the
in-app purchases
that's an interesting number they say
that 20 percent of their premium
upgrades occur in the onboarding safe so
two hours after downloading and
installing the app they then get VIP
branding in they give the user an
insight into which content he will be
able to consume after he paid for the
premium segment that increased them
they're there they're in a purchase
conversion by 53 percent they again also
adjust the prices per country using
those indices that I mentioned before
plus 8% in downloads and again store
listing it's like a it's like a message
we're trying to hammer into your heads
but store listing experiments for them
as well critical localizing the entire
funnel makes makes them more successful
14% increase in downloads all right so
fury check practice check five business
models we did that I discussed right now
there's a lot of information right and
for me and my pals developing this app
now we first have to kind of get our
heads together and think a little bit
what we do with that information crunch
some numbers in order to be able to
choose which monetization we want to do
and where we want to invest
in which segments we want to invest our
money but I think for us and for you as
well there are three main takeaways of
that presentation
first of all lifetime value is not an
end in itself it's not a strategy when
you calculate lifetime value be
realistic make sure that you take into
account the cost of you're actually
having variable cost make sure you're
discounting if you have a long sales
cycle and make sure that your cost of
acquisition is at a fairly decent level
secondly the formula lifetime value
depends on your lifetime times your our
pool the basis of everything thirdly and
that's where I have to agree with Nikko
engagement is the new black because
engagement is the metric that is much
harder to optimize than our pools so if
you get to a high engagement and a low
retention as a high engagement and high
retention and a low churn rate that's
where you're going to be successful so
work on that and then you optimize for
monetization thank you very much
you